our next speaker has actually spoken at
our virtual conferences this is the
first time we have gotten her in person
and on her way here
she's still new to packing
and so her oil in her
carry-on bag and her toiletry bag
spilled all over all of her clothes
so she had the misfortune of having to
spend the afternoon at fifth avenue
shopping for a whole new wardrobe
so everyone please welcome asuma
hi everyone it's a pleasure to be
amongst all of you in person
thank you for coming thank you to the
new york r conference for having me
apologies in advance
i'm going to be talking about a very
sobering issue
which is substance use disorders in this
country
and how we're approaching it at pursue
care
so first when i refer to substance use
disorders and specifically i'll be
focusing on opioid use disorders we're
referring
to the set
of the very significant social
economic
psychological consequences
due to the use and the misuse of a class
of drugs called opioids
in the past two decades we've lost
nearly
half a million people
to
opioids
and
the trends
show that these numbers have quadrupled
in that time
range to put things into perspective
last year
we've lost nearly 140 people to this
every single day
last year
we're losing people around the clock
every five minutes
by the end of my talk we would have lost
four people
we've seen
an increase in these deaths recently in
the last two years
we've already experienced a very steep
increase in 2020 nearly 30 percent
and another increase on top of that
in 2021 with a 15
increase
these numbers from the cdc
are very concerning
and while kovid19 explains some of this
increase it definitely does not account
for trends that we had already seen
prior to the pandemic
these increases are occurring all over
the country
except for a handful of states
most of the country has seen 50 60 70
increases in opioid overdose deaths
and the reasons for these are complex
and vary from state to state
but we could probably start
understanding why
at the county level among 3 000 or so
counties in america
78 percent do not have an opioid
treatment program
unthinkable
30 percent do not have a provider that
is able to dispense life-saving
medications for people suffering from
opioid use disorders
we see further inequalities and
disparities
looking at
gender
looking at race
we continuously see
over the past few years
that women
black people and hispanic people
have significant barriers of access when
it comes to getting the treatment that
they need namely buprenorphine which is
that life-saving medication that they
need
so this is where we come in
pursue care
i'm the director of analytics and
research
at this company
and our mission is to eliminate
every barrier to access for these
patients
starting off with providing telehealth
capabilities for our patients
telehealth has shown that it reduces
inequalities in access to care
it also comes with significant
advantages such as privacy
for our already heavily stigmatized
population
it also allows to have functionality
that keeps our patients better engaged
and that meets them at their comfort
level
and so with that we're proud to have
telehealth services and in-person
clinics
in connecticut florida kentucky maine
up and down the east coast
and we treat all substance use disorders
mainly opioid use disorder alcohol use
disorder
severe mental illness
and other mental health conditions
a little bit about our app
so through telehealth technology and
also in-person clinics
we deliver life-saving medications
we also deliver digital therapeutics
individual and group therapy
psychiatric care
and medications from our own pharmacy
our goals for the data science team
is detecting trends first and foremost
that involves understanding our patient
population
how they interact with our care
and with that
figuring out what are the outcomes that
are meaningful to us and how can we
monitor them
and with that how can we enact
procedural changes to make sure that we
are constantly optimizing our outcomes
for both our patients and our care team
and so this basically becomes a feedback
loop in and of itself
so first off detecting trends
it really begins with our internal
tooling
when i started at pursue care over a
year ago we were still a startup we are
a startup
and with healthcare we have lots of
vendors which do different things
and have data on our patients and our
care team
and this data because it's distributed
across many platforms is structured
differently
and so the challenge
was to bring all these data sources
together
into our data warehouse
but also augmenting it with publicly
available data
to better understand
patient demographics
socioeconomic indicators whether their
area where they're from is resource
burdened facing housing challenges
transportation challenges
all these factors that help us
understand the challenges that our
patients are facing and help us better
tailor our approach to them
and so my work for the past year has
been marrying all these sources together
in a meaningful way into our data
warehouse
and the other significant portion of my
time was dedicated to building
what's called an internal stack this is
a term that i've borrowed from emily
ryderer
the senior analytics manager at capital
one she has a fantastic blog post about
the importance of investing in an
internal stack and i find this graph
perfect to drive that point home
we have a lot of open source packages at
our disposal in our community to do all
sorts of things from database querying
to
deploying our apps and dashboards
but sometimes those packages are really
built to fulfill as many use cases as
possible in a general sense and you may
be better serviced by building your own
package to not only fulfill specific use
cases that you might have that are not
fulfilled by open source packages or to
save some time
and that's exactly what we've done we've
built packages to automate our
extraction transform loading processes
our database connection and querying api
requests we've built packages that
package together public data from
different sources like the american
census bureau and the cdc
and we've built packages for data
manipulation and data visualizations for
steps that we repeat over and over again
across our reports and dashboards
and that has
led to us
building an internal stack that really
is
helping us in efficiently
detecting trends in an automated
and in a reproducible way which is key
so with this stack we're able to then
look at trends that are meaningful to us
such as patient demographics
socioeconomic indicators
healthcare resource utilization
clinical characteristics
and our patients treatment plan journey
how they're interacting with with their
treatment plan
and the way we deliver this to the
various stakeholders in our company
from physicians
broad care team to the c-suite is
powered by our studio connect our studio
connect is first and foremost a
publishing platform
and really what has paid a lot of
dividends for us is the ability to
schedule
reports and have them pretty much hand
delivered to the hands of our
stakeholders
and that has also led to a bunch of
really positive impacts across the
organization in terms of building data
literacy
building buy-in
and we have a really rich exchange with
the other departments in terms of
what are the outcomes that are
meaningful to us based on this
exploration of the trends
so the next broad goal of ours is once
those outcomes were determined is to
monitor them
the outcomes
the main outcomes that matter to us are
engagement so broadly speaking that
means
how patients interact with our
telehealth platform
are they fulfilling open tasks
are they
logging in to their digital therapeutic
and fulfilling modules there
the other important outcome for us is
retention are we retaining these
patients
unfortunately in this patient population
only 30 to 40 percent of people are
retained in care
and because of that a lot of people get
lost to follow up or end up relapsing or
end up passing away so for us retention
is an extremely important metric by
which we measure the efficacy of our
treatment
drug use over time we
we distribute drug tests regularly to
our patients and it's important to see
their drug use over time whether we're
decreasing it as expected or whether
they're relapsing so we're able in real
time to detect any changes
there
and finally adherence to treatment plan
we've designed treatment plans for our
patients and we want to know whether
they're fulfilling all the milestones
and all
the steps predicated by their treatment
plan
so as you can imagine based on these
outcomes the analysis and modeling of
this type of data requires different
approaches depending on the question and
the outcome
and so we're very lucky to be
well serviced by the tidiverse ecosystem
of packages for both data manipulation
and data wrangling along with some other
ones that are not in that ecosystem but
we make extreme heavy use of such as
lubridate for date time manipulations
janitor and skim r for quick summaries
and tabulations of the data
and for the modeling aspect
we are well serviced once again by the
tidy models ecosystem for all steps
involving modeling really from the
splitting of the data all the way to
deployment
and the brms package
and all of that is
delivered
through our studio connect for our
stakeholders
and so one of the last steps for the
data science team is to inform possible
process changes whether they be
operational so changing the way in which
we deliver the care
but also in ways in which we can
personalize treatments because as we
know for most things one size does not
fit all so with that rich information
that we constantly have access to we can
start
modeling whether there are certain
treatment paths that lead to better
outcome so that is an ongoing work
of ours and we hope to publish on this
soon
and so with that we've completed sort of
the loop of our goals for the data
science team at pursuit care and really
what we're about right now is early
detection of trends
continuous improvement
and hopefully better outcomes for our
care team and our patients
so thank you thank you to you for
attending thank you to
my colleagues thank you to our patients
who continuously
inspire us with their courage and their
tenacity
and thank you to our conference
[Applause]
you